tell me what sure you don't believe in
destiny or the lesser evil what do you
believe in what is a Witcher white hair
big ol loner
- very very scary - swords I know who
you are a Witcher is a mutant and their
trainer particular is monster and the
butcher of Barbican you are almost
universally hated by every species on
the continent it's unlikely are gonna
have a cheery personality but Geralt
himself despite the stony exterior is
actually quite good but very capable of
doing bad things
Geralt isn't simply a white knight he is
simply a harsh monster hunter he's an
incredible blend of the two the rumors
about riches arm that they don't have a
motion
you take no prisoners so we hear and
that is perpetuated by them sometimes as
monsters
sometimes there's money rarely boss
[Music]
when they created they undergo
alchemical trials which is a combination
of elixirs and magic which have very
aggressive effects on their bodies this
allows them to take various potions
these potions enhance them in various
and different ways the signs that
witches cast they are basic magic but
very very effective you often see this
very dry humor come through which is one
of the more charming aspects of girls
you smell of death and destiny its onion
err thank you destiny is one of the
major themes which is a force which is
controlling him and indeed the world
around him
Geralt aggravates destiny he doesn't
believe in it but it turns out there may
be a little more to it
the girl's greatest strength is his
capacity to still love despite having
retreated incredibly harshly despite
what he says he still believes in the
goodness of people
and you couple that with
incredible sword skills speed agility
and endurance then you have an
interesting character
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
here's your fastest as in life is
impossible always to be fully prepared
for battle
keep your sword close and keep moving
there's something special about this
girl she's very loyal to the people that
she loves she's built a heart from it
but just hasn't had any experience in
the real world all she's known was a
sheltered life as a princess and this
very secure network of people looking
after her she didn't shoot you Cass
she's very relentless very stubborn and
she's also very naive I think she just
wants to make sure that she doesn't get
trapped in that box would you honor me
with the dogs Martin she loved the
typical conforming life of a princess
and she wants to kind of break free from
that but she suddenly gets dropped in a
very brutal world people after her does
become something very scary
that's it number two know when it's time
to stop nothing
she loses everybody she's known within
one night
a huge theme in The Witcher is the loss
of family in the search for family if
that's the last words that her
grandmother has said to her it means a
great deal and I think that's what keeps
her determined to continue on that's all
she's got left to cling on to it does
mean a lot to her but she doesn't quite
know yet what it means being a princess
doesn't matter anymore she just doesn't
know where to begin
be careful child
[Music]
this place isn't safe if you're alone
and that's the same as every other place
you